bonjour jean françois quand j combes et
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors on l'a dit à la cour
constitutionnelle a confirmé la tenue du
scrutin est ce qu'aujourd'hui tout est
réuni pour que ces élections se passent
bien en centrafrique
mais il n'ya pas que la décision bonjour
d'abord et merci de nous recevoir
la décision de la cour constitutionnelle
est un élément important mais sur le
terrain ce n'est pas l'élément le plus
important la question importante
aujourd'hui est double d'abord combien
de centres applique un bon aller voter
et comment ils se répartissent dans le
pays ça c'est la première question est
la deuxième question c'est est-ce que ce
vote va se dérouler dans des conditions
de sécurité acceptables
nous sommes en train d'observer en vote
effectivement à bangui on voit également
dans quelques villes de province mais il
y a des villes très important des
portions très important du territoire où
on vote pas on voit aussi à l'étranger
un peu mais il faut se rendre compte que
l'essentiel de l'électorat se trouvent
dans les provinces centrafricaine qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu saoul faut une
sorte de cloche de nos votes
il faudra attendre la fin la fin du
décompte pour savoir l'enjeu
en fait c'est que ces élections ne
soient pas seulement les élections de
bangui et que les autorités qui ont
émergé de ces élections là ne puisse pas
être simplement qualifié de président de
la république de bangui ou de député de
la république de bangui su comment le
seuil de temps en temps jusqu'à demain
et qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
l'organisation un général de ce scrutin
est ce que les autorités ont fait ce
qu'il fallait pour que tout se passe
bien
de mon point de vue cette organisation
des élections a péché à différents
égards parce que je suis convaincu que
dans un premier temps le pas qui n'était
pas le pari de l'élection ou la fait à
la va vite
les longs roulement s'est fait à la va
vite dans un pays comme la république
centrafricaine et dans l'état où nous
sommes c'est à dire dans l'état
d'insécurité où nous sommes il aurait
fallu procéder sans doute de façon plus
systématique enregistré plus
systématiquement sur une plus longue
période
par exemple aujourd'hui les personnes
déplacées en république centrafricaine
ne peuvent pas vous arrêter de fêtes 2,2
de l'organisation même des élections
parce que et il y à au moins 708
personnes qui sont des personnes
déplacées sur le territoire les réfugiés
avait été exclu par le gouvernement
contrairement à 2015 2016
donc aujourd'hui vraiment l'enjeu c'est
de savoir qui va voter qui a pu voter
effectivement et sur quel point du
territoire parce que la stabilité des
institutions qui vont être issu de ces
élections là en dépend l ancien
président bozizé a appelé aujourd'hui
les centrafricains à ne pas voter est ce
que c'est un nouvel élément qui est
qu'il y attendre un petit peu plus la
situation autour de ces élections
bien entendu c'est un élément de tension
de peluches et c'est un élément qui
rentre dans un système qui devient
finalement assez incohérent parce que le
président bozizé est allié avec le
président de l'urca c'est-à-dire anicet
georges dologuélé qui lui a appelé à
voter et j'observe également que depuis
hier
même lorsque le président bozizé s'est
prononcé certains de ces des membres de
son parti y compris de 2 2 du bureau
politique de son parti appelle à voter
dans la paix la beauté tout de même et
certaines vérités effectivement voté ce
matin
donc il ya il y a
bon cela tant la situation bien
évidemment et d'une manière générale je
crois que l'enseignement surtout c'est
que cela situe très clairement le
président bozizé en tant que personne
dans la coalition plutôt que alors que
son parti son parti ne fut pas
totalement
jean-françois qu'angie combat dernière
question que peut-on attendre de fuzz
scrutin en centrafrique est ce que le
président sortant à toi deraa peut
éventuellement aubry y ait un second
mandat mais bien sûr il est en train
d'appliquer le second mandat je vous ai
entendu tout à leur dire qu'il partait
favori je n'en suis pas si sûr si on
suit
si en suisse les discussions entre
centrafricains sont enfuis les rumeurs
centrafricaine parce que dans ce pays
veut pas que ce refus absolument
comment dire illusoire de penser avoir
des sondages il se présente pour un
second mandat on va voir si il est élu
et il faut espérer qu'il n'y ait pas de
fraudes massives comme on a toujours
soupçonné les élections dans les
élections en république centrafricaine
par le passé merci beaucoup
jean-françois quand j'ai comblé d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes président du
mouvement debout et solidaire
centrafrique et professeur à l'école de
droit à l'université à paris 1 panthéon
sorbonne merci beaucoup